so go go complete on a tangent that's
how i completely feel about gender of
your parties
i don't i don't understand the point of
gender reveal part i've seen so many
[ __ ] like absurd gender about
gender reveal party clips on like tick
tock and stuff like that where i'm just
like
this is just hilarious now did you see
the one where it's like
[ __ ] what was it it was like there was
like a a balloon like a giant [ __ ]
balloon like you know maybe like this
this is the weirdest [ __ ] tangent
we've ever done no because because one
of what i was what i was thinking was
like
no i was just gonna say like there's
just like a giant like six seven foot
balloon that this guy carries
yeah and he's just like all right i'm
gonna pop it and it just explodes into
this like colored like powder that just
completely fills up the backyard no
because what i'm thinking right is okay
the point of gender reveal party
is to reveal the gender of the baby
right right
and celebrate that but like at which
point
do you does like agenda get revealed and
the father's just like
oh it's it's it's a girl oh
karen karen get the get the go
get the coat hanger we're doing it again
like what what kind of what kind of
reaction do you expect
the father and the mother to have you
know what i mean it's like what human
like most normal people will be like
whether it's a guy or a girl
the reaction's gonna be the same you're
gonna have a kid i just think that we
celebrate too many things
you know i think we have enough things
to celebrate the hardest is to just say
it's a boy
like how hard is it it's like having the
kid's birthday like not enough
like we don't just like i don't i like
to me i legitimately don't understand
like
we have so many things to celebrate it's
[ __ ] who's planning all this [ __ ]
like who has this much free time
honestly i i barely can like get
christmas plans together
like who who has this is it the woman
she's pregnant shouldn't she be focused
on that like i don't
i don't get it i wonder if there's like
self-fulfilling prophecy of like some
people working in retail in america when
a person comes in being like give me all
of your blue dye
i need as much blue dye as possible and
they're like oh [ __ ] all right another
one of these all right
but yeah back to attack on titan
that was a weird transition that's a
weird tangent
bottom line stop [ __ ] complaining
about attack on time it's good
i just feel like i just feel like it's
like because you know
i think there's a bunch of edge people
out there who are just like i don't want
to admit
that attack with titan is the best thing
right now yeah i'm i don't want to give
it more clout than it deserves
and you know you see these [ __ ] god
awful takes on twitter being like yeah
it was boring dropped it right away
it's like who cares just let the people
who are enjoying it [ __ ] enjoy it
yeah like it's good
stop [ __ ] on that's the thing it's
like you can have you can have an
opinion about it right like if you get
[ __ ]
[ __ ] whatever don't [ __ ] harass the
animators over it yeah it's the same
thing with like when game of thrones is
like around right people
like you know people just want to be
that person who's like yeah i don't like
game of thrones
uh yeah whatever yeah are you happy
about it [ __ ] that's lame bro i'm not
i'm not excited about it i'm not excited
about anything bro except for the gender
reveal party
yeah the only thing i get excited for is
my baby's gender
you know what i mean like i don't know
yeah and for some reason
you know i mean it does happen in other
genres as well but for some reason
who are these i don't even know the
[ __ ] ants of these craters that
twitter how are they finding this [ __ ]
why and why are they finding this [ __ ]
just to [ __ ] act now but tell them
it's [ __ ]
right as if like one of the anime is
going to be like oh thanks for your
feedback we'll change it to you yeah
like
they go to their annual meeting like yo
guys you're seeing this people people
don't like it what the [ __ ] yeah so like
uh mikasa276 on twitter said that
we should just completely change the
episode it just changed studios
yeah like what director's gonna be like
alright fam i got you i mean it kind of
sucks that
you know in the time where the japanese
industry and japanese staff members are
starting to you know we want them to
open up yeah to open up more to the
international community
this is the [ __ ] they have to deal with
for some of like the biggest profile
i kind of want to just go up and be like
don't open up it's not worth it don't
don't go don't go this far i do think
you know there's a good amount of people
who are probably selling hate who
probably don't want it to open up right
to them i think
it it's you know it's the same thing
with like the idol and like kind of
almost like the whole life fan base a
little bit where that like we don't want
our
our people to interact outside ruin them
we don't want the normies we don't want
we don't yeah we don't want like the
american corporations getting their
fingers in our japanese like anime you
know i mean
there's a lot of people who are like
that right as as if they're japanese
themselves
yeah i mean a lot of the time it does
come from a place of you know
non-japanese yeah
yeah we like our country i get it if
they were japanese yeah yeah but
most if not all right it's like in your
video when you did the uh the anime
studio tour
yeah and like the guy who was the
director of the studio was like oh we
have foreign fans
yeah and like kila genuinely yeah so the
ceo of cloverworks genuinely didn't know
that they had
i mean a lot of people don't know that
like if he goes on twitter
you're [ __ ] yeah people they're gonna
tell him to kill himself what like
i would be like no they don't exist
don't they don't no they don't they
don't
honestly like like it's embarrassing i'm
just saying you do to make you feel
better
i mean i suppose if you think about it
it's the same way if it's the same
mentality of like for example if you
found out that trash tatus
or something had japanese fans you know
what i mean it's just like oh there's
people in japan who watch us we have
russian fans what's what
yeah what have a russian dub what what's
going on here
get emails every week be like you guys
know you have like a russian dog yeah
yeah